[Música]
me gustaría pensar que a nadie de acá le
hicieron bullying pero lo más probable
es que muchos sufrieron de esto
la cuestión es que ustedes no son como
el sueño
supongan ser que yo ahora les digo que
dos más 12 5
ya lo voy a decir vagina esta burra del
escenario
pero si no cree en esta supuesta
afirmación que acabo de hacer porque les
van a creer a la gente que los critica
que tienen menos sentido todavía dicen
como no podéis usar bikini si sos gorda
es ilegal acaso cuando hay que pensar
para que yo lo podamos usar lo que los
gustos
me puse a reflexionar el que la está
pasando peor en esta situación es el que
critica porque gasta su tiempo en
procesar las cosas malas del otro
ni que le fueran a dar un premio por ser
mala persona así tenemos una razón más
para tratar a la gente como si todos
fuéramos iguales
a mí me pasa que cuando conozco gente
que todavía no me vio en persona la
conversación fluye pero como soy muy
alta cuando me ven en realidad es algo
así como
su voz
y después nunca te volver a hablar pero
la cuestión es que te miran como si
fueras el monte everest como si fueras
anormalmente grande
a mí también me pasaba que cuando salí a
la calle con mis amigas ellas como son
de estatura perfecta por así decirlo
todos les preguntan si le pasaban el
whatsapp animación preguntas como de
alta y el clima ya arriba qué onda
pero después te das cuenta que nunca te
lo vas a volver a cruzar y todo perfecto
yo voy a comedia musical y es un lugar
muy difícil para adaptarse no es fácil
ser un introvertido del teatro pero
cuando tenemos que pasar a cantar hay
algunos chicos que no quieren no por
míos que les vaya mal sino porque
piensan que los van a criticar
la primera clase yo tampoco quería pasar
estaba aterrorizada de que me fueran a
decir algo porque como mi grupito y yo
éramos los más chicos y también los más
nuevos
era horrendo y encima después llegabas a
tu casa tus papás te preguntaban cómo te
fue la clase y uno se queda como bueno
que yo ahora tengo otras cualidades
pero una de las peores maneras de
mejorar ese estado comparándose con
otros porque siempre hay gente mejor y
peor que uno
yo sé que va a haber gente que va a
seguir a merced de la gente que los
critican después de esta charla
querida gente les quiero decir algo
esa pollera te queda hermosa sin
importar el largo
puedes usar rosas entonces es un pedazo
de tela
usa esa remera corta aunque para muchos
no tengas el cuerpo ideal
porque cuando uno te dice esto es
probable que te está afectando algo
porque estos son cosas que te dicen
cuando uno ya se le nubló la mente y no
puede ver lo hermoso que es uno porque
en realidad sólo tenemos dos enemigos
uno es la opinión de otros no la segunda
en la que es más relevante es la visión
que uno tiene sobre sí mismos
podemos aprender a descartar este primer
enemigo de nuestras vidas muy fácilmente
pero también tenemos que aprender a
querernos a nosotros con nuestras
virtudes y defectos porque si la visión
sobre nosotros mismos es débil es mucho
más probable que te afecte lo que
piensen los demás
una maestra una vez dijo a uno le pueden
robar la mochila le pueden robar la casa
le pueden robar el auto le pueden robar
absolutamente todo excepto tu forma de
pensar por eso es tan relevante es algo
que le define como persona ahora van a
dejar que gente con argumentos
pesimistas construye su identidad
imagínense si lo feo que es que te roben
una billetera los fijos que va a hacer
que te roben la identidad
pero al final
si tenés pancita sos obeso
si son flacos os anoréxico si su saltó
sobre una jirafa si son bajos es un
duende si sos extrovertido son re
confiado sexos introvertido no tienes
vida social hagas lo que hagas seas como
seas te van a criticar y eso no se puede
cambiar porque siempre va a haber gente
con la intención de lastimarte
respirado pensar lo bueno que tienes y
seguí adelante y si en algún momento la
cosa te afecta
pedí ayuda siempre va a haber amigos que
estén pasando por lo mismo que vos así
que sería muy bueno que se junten y
entre todos se ríen de los malos
momentos y es puesta en canción es una
obra de teatro o una buena charla te da
muchas gracias